there are certainly a few strong players
coming both with me from Paris and also
we didn't play in Paris
I think maximum again will be very
strong level blood
maybe Vichy he was I mean he won the
champion showdown last year in psychosis
lots of guys are in very good shape
recently for Magnussen MBL played
extremely well in Paris which same
format
Levin was very dominant in Norway every
time a world champion was playing a
tournament is always your favorite so I
think Magnus well especially in
marketing believe here which are Magnus
Maksim definitely well a young a
firmness is especially strong in this
format every obvious good player and
everyone can win this money so you never
know I cannot say about anyone
for example Magnus Carlsen just win in
Paris so it's very hard to repeat it
again here so maybe he's not so clear
for it is all other person I think in my
opinion I don't see myself as a favorite
in this event I think Magnus Carlsen is
the favorite in every event takes part
in I've done that vassula graph have
done very well in Paris will be natural
to take him as well
I think Wesley saw has lost his form
entirely I don't think he's you can be
fighting for things yes very likely the
maximum mashallah grafton maybe a guy
like me hope in shape it's difficult to
predict who is going to win because you
know everybody can play well but then
just one birthday and you know English
it goes very quick you can lose one game
after another getting irritated by
yourself by your play and then and then
you just spoil it all but it's quite
easy 3d who is going to be the main
challenger going to fight for the first
place and I'm afraid if I might not be
in this Restless but we will see